- Nice to see you.
(audience applauds)
- Nice to see you, too.
You know, I may not be from
Texas, but my dad actually is.
- Oh really?
Where, do you know?
- So there we go.
- He's from Johnson County.
- What?!
Are you (beep) me right now?
- [Jackson] No, I'm dead serious.
- I'm from Johnson and Tarrant.
- Really?
- Yeah,
I lived in both growing up, yeah.
- So, I didn't really
know my father very much
growing up.
- Okay, me neither, ha!
- Hey, all right.
- High five!
Hey, therapy!
- But I do know
that's where he's from.
Yeah, exactly. (laughs)
- Yeah, that's awesome.
- That's where I am right now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This is therapy, right?
- This is therapy.
- Oh, thank god.
- Welcome to my couch, yeah.
(Jackson laughs)
I can talk a lot about that issue, but no.
But you had a mini "Dawson's Creek"
reunion with Michelle, right,
at the Oscars?
- I did, yeah.
- How is that,
(audience cheers)
like when you run into each other like-
- [Audience Member] Pacey!
- [Kelly] Yes, okay.
- [Jackson] Thank you, darling.
- Still excited, still very excited.
It's 20 years, though.
That's a crazy amount of time.
- 25, I think.
- Oh, 25?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
Over 20 years.
Look how serious-
- [Jackson] It was a little bit less
gray in the beard.
- What is she saying?
She looks very serious.
- She was saying,
"I can't believe you're a father!"
(both laugh)
- No, but that's what's so cool.
Like, years later, you
knew each other so young.
- [Jackson] Yeah,
you were the kids.
- And like,
Yeah!
- Yeah, it's, I mean,
this, we don't get to see
each other all that often.
- Yeah.
- She has her kids.
She lives in New York.
I have my kid, we live here.
But that was a lovely night,
and just having the
opportunity to see her.
I hadn't met her new husband
since they got together.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- [Jackson] Who's the third
person in that photograph.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, yeah, I mean, it's a
funny thing to get, like,
the most fancy dress-up party
that you can possibly do
and then have a high school reunion,
but that's what we did!
- Yeah.
(Jackson laughs)
I love that, though.
It's fun.
- Yeah.
- You actually did "Mighty Ducks"
years before "Dawson's Creek" and that,
is that hard?
Like, I just think, whenever I was a kid
I did not want to stand out.
(Jackson laughs)
And like, when you're an actor
in such a huge movie like that
and then you go back to school,
was it cool, or did people pick on you?
- It was a little bit of both.
- Okay.
- So one, I'm Canadian,
(audience cheers)
so hockey, obviously.
- [Kelly] Oh, people are nice.
- Oh no,
we take hockey really, really seriously
- No, I know, but people are nice there.
There's no mean kids, right?
I feel like you're all nice.
- I hate to break it to you, but-
- Don't burst that bubble for us.
- Yeah, we are all nice, all the time.
- Okay, thank you.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, high school, you know,
it had its challenges, definitely.
- Yeah.
- And going away,
you know, first off you
disappear for a couple months
and nobody knows why you're gone.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then you come back
and nobody cares why you were gone.
And then the movie comes
out and they're like,
"So you think you're special now?"
- That's what I mean.
(Jackson laughs)
Like, kids can be so hard.
- [Jackson] Yeah, kids are tough.
- Yeah.
- But on the flip side of it,
you know, for me, I think acting
can be a difficult journey
for a lot of young people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But for me,
it gave me a place to focus
and to have something that
grown-ups would respect me for.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, if I went
and I worked hard and I
showed up and knew my stuff-
- Responsible.
- I could actually
get respect from grownups,
which you definitely don't in high school.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know,
you're the problem.
So, it actually, for me, was a really
healthy release and place to focus.
Even if not all of my fellow
students enjoyed my success.
- Yeah, who cares?
(Jackson laughs)
They're jealous.
So wait, do you remember
how you found out,
like when you got the role?
That's a huge role for a kid.
- Yeah, so-
- Or anybody.
- The, in Vancouver
public elementary school,
there's these things
called "mini schools."
So the mini schools, like, one
is called (indistinct) TREK,
that takes, you get to be outside.
Anyway, I went to the art school
'cause I wanted to be an actor.
- Yeah.
- So, one of the things
that you have to do at the mini schools,
'cause you're in public school,
is raise money to pay for
anything that you want.
So every year you do these phone drives.
So I was, like, in the
utility closet at the school,
and my mom called through
the central switchboard
to be like, "Hey, guess what?
(Kelly laughs)
You got the movie!"
as I'm in the middle of being like,
"Hi, would you like to donate $5 to,
to Ideal Mini?"
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- From your janitor closet?
- Yeah, exactly.
So that's the glamorous
space that my career started.
- I love that.
(Jackson laughs)
That's so cool.
So, I just need to verify something-
- [Jackson] Mhm.
- From Wikipedia
that we found out.
Is it true that you were
kicked out of school
because of the Jon Stewart show?
Is this-
- Yes.
- He's very powerful.
- So, he is.
- Yeah.
- Wickedly powerful.
I like him a lot.
- You have no idea.
Me too!
- Yeah.
- I like him too much.
That's why I got kicked
out of high school.
- Oh!
- So, it's actually the second time
I got kicked out of high school.
That's a different story.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- My mother's gonna be so proud
that I'm telling this story.
- So proud.
- So after I left Ideal Mini,
after they politely
requested that I leave,
I went to my local high school
(Kelly laughs)
which was Kits High School,
and Jon Stewart's show was
on at two in the morning,
local time, Vancouver.
- Yeah.
- So I would stay up to watch Jon Stewart,
and it was also during the OJ trial.
So then in the morning, I'd be tired,
I'd flip on the TV, I'd be like,
"Maybe I'll just watch
a couple hours of OJ
instead of going to the
first three classes."
And eventually, they thought
(audience laughs)
that was not a good
educational program for me,
and they asked me to
leave that school, too.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah.
Jon Stewart and OJ got me
kicked outta high school.
- But look at you now.
Your mom has to be proud of you.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Look at you now.
So, is it true
(audience applauds)
that you live in your childhood home?
- [Jackson] Yeah.
- That is crazy cool.
- Yeah.
- How did that come about?
It hasn't been, has it been
in your family the whole time?
Or did you have to, like, buy it back?
- No, so that father that
I didn't know very well.
- Yeah.
- When my parents got divorced
he sold the house.
Flash forward many, many, many years.
I was in the neighborhood
that that house was in,
and a friend of mine was
getting married there.
And the day after, I went
to go see the old house,
and the guy who had
bought it from my father
was standing outside on his porch.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And thank god,
I was with my friend Daniel.
And he called up and was like,
"Hey, you know, this is
my friend's old house."
And I looked at it, I was like,
"Man, I put that sticker in
the window when I was a kid."
And he'd left this sticker
in my childhood bedroom.
And he goes, "Oh, you mean
up in the dragon room?"
And the dragon room is
my childhood bedroom
that had this big mural
of a dragon painted on it
by my mother's friend.
- Yeah.
- Because when I was a kid,
I was obsessed with dragons.
So long story short, at the end of, like,
a seven-hour conversation, I said,
"Hey man, if you ever
consider selling this house,
please let me try buying it."
And I, we're talking 20 years ago now.
- Yeah.
- And
he called me up the next morning
at 9 A.M. and he was like,
"Man, it just feels right.
Were you serious?"
I was like, "Absolutely!"
So I bought that house.
And I thought that I was buying it for me,
to heal that wound of my family rupture.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it turns out,
I was just holding onto it for 20 years,
because let me tell
you, taking my baby girl
and putting her into
the crib in my bedroom
for the first time-
- Aw, the same-
- Under the dragon?
(audience awws)
(Jackson exhales)
- That's really powerful.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
I didn't have that either.
A friend of mine has this song
called "The House That Built Me",
and I was listening to
it, and I cried so hard.
I was like, "Not everybody gets this."
- [Jackson] Yeah, no, it's-
- Like, not everybody knows that,
that feeling, or you've moved a lot or-
- And for us, yeah.
It was just, you know,
all divorces are troublesome,
but, the-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
They're, you know, from experience,
yeah, they're not fun.
- Yeah, not great.
Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right, right.
So, when my parents split,
my dad, unfortunately,
wasn't a very good man, and
he just sort of took off.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so,
we had this major rupture.
And to be able to come full circle
for myself, into this house, but now
to be a father in this place?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, it is
just magical to witness
her experience all the,
the joys that I remember from that place.
- Yeah.
- And be able to
actually be in the other seat now,
and know that I'm gonna provide her
with a real man and a
real father in her life.
- And that's the coolest part, right?
Is, I feel that too.
I never really realized
until I had my own kids that,
what a loss I really-
- Yeah.
- Like what a loss it was.
- A hundred percent.
- And then you have kids, and I'm like,
and it's almost like, you know what,
thank you for showing
me, like, what not to do.
- [Jackson] Yeah.
- Like, you know,
because I, you don't understand
all you missed out on, you know?
And like, I don't ever
wanna do that with my kids.
- And where, yeah, and like,
where the pain actually,
because you, you learn.
- Yeah.
- So from like, how old
was I, six years old.
From six years old, for
the rest of my life,
my father was gone.
- Me too.
- Right? Okay.
So you learn all those
coping mechanisms and
people tell you all
sorts of stupid advice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, "Oh, you gotta
figure it out with this
guy, this stranger."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, and I never did.
So-
- [Kelly] I tried.
- I said my piece with him once.
- Yeah.
- But I never tried to
fix the-
- I tried, it did not go well.
- Yeah, yeah, I-
- It's like, more damage.
- Yeah, exactly. (laughs)
I got the sense from him that it was
a more damage offer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Rather than a healing offer.
- I collect red flags, so. (laughs)
(Jackson and audience laugh)
Wee!
Yeah.
- Should we switch seats?
- So, let me get on the couch.
(both laugh)
- But yeah, I mean it's
just, you don't know,
you don't know all this
stuff you're carrying.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then this little,
like-
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Pure, innocent face pops into the world,
and all of a sudden you're like,
"Oh wow!
I wasn't over that."
- Turns out, I just
buried it real deep.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- So let me, like,
thank you for teaching me this and
boy, you're in for a ride.
- Yeah.
(Jackson laughs)
But also, like, thank
you for showing me it.
Like, I really do, I invest so
much in my children and I'm,
I'm there.
I'm really present when I need to be,
because I just know what
it's like to be abandoned.
And so it's like, it's
kind of a weird thing
to say thank you for, but it's like,
you know, I'm really appreciative,
hyper-appreciative of that time, you know?
So, I don't think everybody-
- [Jackson] Yeah.
- Necessarily knows that
if you've never gone without, you know.
- I, so, yeah.
It's an odd dynamic.
Like, he's passed away since, but-
- Mine too.
- If the man was here,
I would have a hard time, like,
thanking him for the difficulties.
- Yeah.
- But when I made,
when I said my piece with him, the,
I didn't know this is
what I needed to say,
but what I actually ended
up saying to him was,
"I don't want you to
think I hate you anymore."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because if you hadn't
made things so hard, I don't get here.
- Exactly.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- And so,
I can say that even more so now at 44,
like, if you hadn't
put all those obstacles
in my way when I was a young person-
- [Kelly] Had to push.
- I wouldn't know
how the, and I wouldn't
know the type of man
and father I wanna be now to my baby girl.
- Yeah, yeah, I agree.
I agree with that, as well.
- Yeah.
- Okay, your new series
is called "Fatal Attraction."
- [Jackson] Yes.
- Is it like, obviously,
based off the film?
- Based off the film, yeah.
- Okay, so where does it pick up?
Does it pick up somewhere, or does it...
- No, so it's not a sequel.
We're actually retelling a
version of the original story.
- Okay.
- So it's not set in 1989.
It's set, well, in 2018 and 2023.
But we're telling the same sort of,
yeah, that's exactly,
bad, bad boy.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
- He makes some bad choices,
is all I'm gonna say.
- Okay.
- So we're telling
the same story of a man
who steps out on his wife,
has this affair with a woman
who is psychologically fragile,
and then blows up both of their lives.
But because we have all
of this additional time,
because it's television, in our show,
which they didn't really
deal with in the movie,
he actually has to deal
with the repercussions of his actions.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause if you go
back and watch the original movie,
which is a fantastic movie
and I highly recommend it.
- Yeah.
- But it is shocking
how un-fussed he is by his own behavior.
He's like, not at all
remorseful of the fact
that he had an affair on his wife.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just not at all.
- Yeah.
But just so you know, those people exist.
(Kelly laughs)
- I mean, I feel like-
- Just, in 2023.
(Kelly laughs)
- Okay, fair.
Fair.
- Just so you know, it's like,
"That never happens now."
(audience laughs)
- I just, maybe it's,
you know what, I was
raised in a, by a mom,
so maybe it's like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Just being around women
all my life, but it just,
in 1989, I just feel like
we were in a different conversation?
- No, totally.
We can't get away with certain things now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- At least,
you can be that guy, but
you have to hide it somehow.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
And not on film anymore.
- And not on film.
Yeah, that's-
- [Kelly] Don't parade it
around and celebrate it? (laughs)
- Yeah, that's not working anymore.
- I love that.